[Applaudissements]
eric est enfin pris par exemple de
courant pour des ricains il ya tous les
soirs un épisode mais me direz que c'est
pas tout à fait le même ici et
maintenant puisque cyril est candidat à
présidence de france télévisions donc on
est en train d'adapter on est en train
de tourner chaque jour un nouvel épisode
de derrick c'est vraiment un derrick
vraiment du sud de l'allemagne quoi vous
allez vous en rendre compte regarde
[Musique]
tiens c'est la liste pour la miss va du
petit et christophe maé attention c'est
à 20h et trois chansons avec ce qui m'a
pris cet [ __ ] il n'a pas tiré me faire
attendre
la forme est d'inviter le ricoh macias
ouais ça c'est pour moi assez inquiet
focus auto qu inspecteur je peux vous
parler de ce groupe s'il vous plaît sur
la vita tâche un peu plus de remarquer
ce qu'il ya encore voilà tout le monde a
été invité à la fête sauf moi
est ce que c'est normal mais bien sûr
que c'est normal tu as vu comment
s'habiller et tu veux te pointer sans
déconner mettre un foulard avec lâchera
n'a quitté même changé walo c'est trop
tard je te préviens tue point que ce
soir je s'arrachent les couilles sur
fantasy c'est moi c'est déjà une lutte
la gueule toi l'abbé sur gueule tu
t'éclates ya goûté les maquereaux de
presse n'est pas terminée là bas tu l'as
aux [ __ ] raconté monfils la graphie
ne tirez pas sur ma vie cours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
l'époux